Her low freak bitches. What are the
things that you're seeing these days?
I wanted to bring this up with
you. Now that you're here, Jamie,
pull up my Twitter profile.
There was a tweet that I posted last
night that I found this guy got in trouble
for a fucking joke and he
wound up leaving this, uh,
this company that, uh, I think
he's involved in video games.
He's been on Dave Rubin's show and
Dave Rubin was a raving about him.
Look at this.
Look what this Guy Ron,
let's click on the one on the left
right there. This is what he wrote. Ah,
peace and quiet hashtag a day
without a woman just to fucking joke.
Just real simple Joe. Now
go to the next one. Jamie.
Look with the fucking international
business times wrote kind of funny.
He's Colin Moriarity resigns after
targeting women in racist joke.
Insist it's his personal
decision to resign racist.
Did you see your race known as
women or women of fucking race?
Now did you know that that a
dad joke about women is racist.
That gets some brain surgeons over
there. Ib Times got, wow, that's crazy.
Get Some Vac of vacancies for real
journalists to click on that, that,
that quote again, look at this
international business times. Fuck you.
Why did he resign?
Whoever this guy is,
what does this guy by Mike Lewis
Sluices Luke's is whatever you name is.
Fuck you man. That is
what you are doing, right?
That is virtue signaling
at its very worst.
You know that's not a racist joke
that that what you did is you,
you targeted that guy,
you went after that guy and you,
you did it in a very deceptive way.
That is it is. If anything, it's,
it's just a joke and you might
not like it. You might think,
well that's not really good if you're
working in an environment with women,
you know, like you don't want to hear
them talk like that might be sexist.
It's a fucking joke and saying
that it's racist. Is it?
That is so fucking deceptive and
manipulative and they think I flipped back
though. Calamari all, I
don't know why he resigned.
Maybe they're going to fire him, but
what's this guy's article say? Well,
how does he tie in race so that it's
got to be that he has to have something
that go to the, let's go to the article.
There's no, there's no fucking connection.
How could there be a connection unless
y'all know, unless that's a race,
unless women are a fucking race.
It's just crazy that someone would think
that it's okay to do that. I liked it.
This guy is punching back though.
I kind of liked it.
He's not just taking
the quietly apologizing.
Well he quit whatever
organization that is. Um,
that he was working for kind of funny
and just decided and so many people that
he was working with shit on him for that
joke. It's just a Goddamn joke. And what,
why is everybody so sensitive today and
is it that they're so sensitive or is it
that they're super ready to jump
down other people's throats?
Because they sense that this
is a very hostile environment.
And when you tell jokes, people
are, what, what are you doing?
Is this it okay when
you, oh, he updated it.
And by the way,
people,
I don't think it's the people who took
down the word racist as raised it lost.
You described it as a joke tweeted
by comic, I was racist. It was not.
The article has been changed to
reflect this. Still Fuck you. Fuck you.
Fuck you man. This is, we've
got a real problem today.
And that people are jumping down
people's throats for jokes and they're,
they're doing it because they sense
that they're soft targets, that it's,
there's going to be a pylon and
they sense the pile on the goal. Oh,
this guy made a joke about women.
Let's get him a bunch of people going
to be getting them. This is a free shot.
It's kicking someone while they're down.
It's what it is.
It's a drunk girl at the party and
you're sticking it right in her ass. He,
it's basically the same thing.
They're mean the same thing. No,
but it's the same shitty mentality
behind it. It's that people like, uh,
people, uh, they don't feel offended.
They just feel it's a chance to be mean.
And you can be mean to someone who does
something fucked up or says something
racist or whatever. So yeah,
people are just content.
That joke is every episode of
married with children. It is.
It's every episode patient. Quite,
yeah. David, a woman, Sha, quiet,
peaceful family come on every episode of,
of um, the honeymooners. So same thing.
That was the word to the moon, Alice.
It was threatening beating her.
I know with his fist
punching her into interstellar space
and it was so great with that though.
There's literally people
would criticize that,
but she was like the first feminist
on TV because she won every exchange.
She was,
she was always right.
He was at the big dumb fat cell
and he was always fucking up.
He does get mad and he would always get
mad and she would all the writing and
that the fucking,
the,
there'll be emasculating line she had
there that some of the best lines.
I don't want my salary to leak out
your salary. Couldn't drip out. Oh,
what a fucking great line here.
Right. Your salary couldn't drip out.
It's a great show. Humiliating.
And you know what, one,
another thing about that show that was
so great about the honeymooners and well
that was the last one. A lot of
previous sitcoms. No, I mean this is a,
there was a groundbreaking new thing at
the time that was a, it was on a cow,
I think. Cavalcade it was
called. It was some like the,
all the y'all lost ones are like, some
of them are 15 minutes, 20 minutes.
They were part of it as a sketch show.
The honeymooners was a sketch in
an overall show. It'd be like,
it was like dice when he started.
He was just dice as a character in any
Clay's act. That's what that was. Wow.
It just became this thing which
didn't do well and they uh,
came back years later,
but so funny.
But you could never do that shit today
when you can do it all in the family.
You can do it. There was a million
movies that you couldn't do.
You know what I mean?
You try watching like older movies.
What was it that we looked at
recently in that we were lucky.
There's no way you could do that today.
There was a,
an old movie that was a really fucking
funny movie from like the nineties I
remember which one. It won't kill
a mockingbird guy. He's a guy.
He's a bad guesser or not. Definitely.
You probably couldn't do that one either.
No, it was like one of those, Oh, oh, it
was national Lampoon's vacation. I'm like,
good Lord. I watch national
Lampoon's vacation and she's like,
there's no fucking way you could do that
movie today. There we go. We get to,
I don't remember it.
I've seen it was sexist and eh,
you mean every massage and
Dick? Like everything. Yeah,
like there's no humor.
Like humor has to be,
it has to pass like these
rigid filters now. Yeah.
It's not as simple as say
something inappropriate,
but it's still funny that you
don't necessarily mean like,
one of my favorite comics and I think a
great at one of the greatest of all time,
is Roseanne Barr.
I really put her as very funny.
I put her as one of the most important
comics of all time because I think that
what Roseanne did was she,
she had that powerful fuck
you comedy as a woman.
And it was really one of the first ever,
cause women were more sedate in there,
even if they were really
good comics like Joan Rivers.
It was a different sort
of style of delivery.
But Roseanne came out like a
hardcore man club comic. Yeah.
You know, and she was shitting on her
husband for being a fucking loser.
It'd be at fat.
And it was just hard and slamming.
And I didn't take offense as a man. I
didn't hear those jokes and going, yeah,
I can't believe she shitting on man.
Can't believe she's shitting on man.
It was just funny to stop this.
This is success.
And it was so this guy saying, uh,
you know, a peace and quiet, like,
I'm sorry if you're not a Yappy cunt, that
joke shouldn't offend you. Right. Okay.
If you're a person who's a
great conversationalist and
you also happen to have a
vagina that shouldn't bother you, even in
the slightest. And it probably doesn't.
It's just like,
oh,
I know that should bother me so
I'm going to be shitty about it.
I don't even think people care that much.
I think they just liked to,
to attack other people.
Exactly.
That's what I'm talking about and that's
why fuck you to that guy who wrote that
article and especially fuck you
because he called him a racist. Yeah.
He did that on purpose because he
knew it was going to be clickbait.
Who's going to get people to go to that
article and it was good to get people
more excited about it without
even reading it. Yeah.
Cause all they need is the article.
Most people are so fucking busy,
they don't have time to
read the whole thing.
They're so quick to pull the trigger.
All the, all they need is the title.
What's the title? Oh, that's good enough.
Fuck him. Let's tweet at him. Yeah,
let's shame him.
Okay.